I was surprised to see that the rife spikes my EMF meter. I know rife uses EMFs that are supposed
to be safe, but I was surprised to see my meter spike red is this normal. Is my meter bad?
If my meter spike had red for safe rife EMFs, then how can I trust what my meter tells me?
I'm confused about this. Well, I don't know what meter you're using, and even if you
piped it on the chat and said you're using XYZ meter, I'm not ultra familiar with each meter,
so I wouldn't be able to help that wouldn't help me at all. But the rife is going to emit frequencies.
So it is an EMF electromagnetic frequency that is harmful, is a frequency that is a higher range
frequency, much higher than your rife can produce. So the rife, the true rife, and until
your robot cannot produce frequencies that are in a dangerous EMF, you know, the danger frequencies.
So you don't have to worry about the rife producing. People ask me that a lot of the case review.
I'm sensitive to EMFs, will the rife make that worse? The rife can't produce frequencies
in the hertz level high enough. It has to be in the killer hertz level. The rife only goes,
the true rife only goes to 12,000 hertz that the until your robot only goes to 30,000 hertz.
That's all you need for healing. Those are healing frequencies. The killer hertz and the mega hertz
frequencies are the EMF frequencies that are dangerous. So you can't hurt yourself with EMFs. The EMFs
and EMF is electromagnetic frequency. So the rife is producing electromagnetic frequencies,
but not in a range that is the harmful EMF frequencies.